look listen
i hate to say this but
flying cars
will never be a thing now i know i know
they are so epic they are 420 thanos
keanu reeves marvel epic science
machines and they might even turn you
into a pickle however in real life
flying cars would either be a completely
impractical b hazardous c detrimental to
your mental health the entire concept is
just non-viable and when i say
non-viable i don't mean we will not see
any flying cars period i do think
they'll have some kind of niche
application but nothing beyond that
flying cars by and large are just a
stupid concept and if they were just
that i wouldn't really bother you know
there's plenty of stupid ideas out there
and they usually die on their own
however i also think that flying cars
present a unique and exotic danger and
multiple dangers in fact and that's the
reason why this video exists so how and
why are flying cars such a bad idea
that's what we're going to look at but
before moving on a quick word from
today's sponsor the one and only raid
shadow legends raid shadow legends is an
online champion based free-to-play game
available both on pc and mobile and when
i say champion based i really mean that
the game has over 600 of them all of
them belonging to unique factions with
their own distinct lores here we're
going to take a look at one of these
factions the orcs who often get a bad
rap in fantasy for being violent savages
so here's some footage of orcs being
violent savages and what i like about
the orcs is the same thing i like about
the game itself namely just how detailed
the champions are clearly a ton of work
went into the visuals and i'm all here
for it raid shadow legends is basically
what would happen if george r.r martin
made a pokemon game you assemble a team
of champs and go on an adventure which
mostly consists of you beating people up
and it's super fun being an mmo raid has
a full event schedule including a
particularly busy halloween lineup
towards the end of the month pvp
tournaments fragment events where you
can get brand new legendary champions
including a special spooky scary
halloween champ raid has a massive
constantly growing player base and
there's some big content updates coming
out very soon so now is a great time to
get started since you're here and
presumably watching this you'll get a
huge head start bonus through my link in
the description or my qr code on the
screen with those as a new player you
get 200k silver an xp boost an energy
refill one ancient chart and a champion
as a bonus as soon as you log in the
rewards will be available for 30 days so
don't waste time click the link or scan
the qr code and start playing today
thank you for checking out red shadow
legends ads like this help support what
i do and now back to the program
alright so how and why are flying cars
such a horrendously bad idea let's look
at the first point practicality so the
reason why we came up with this thing
called transportation is to get to
places quicker so we can divide
traveling into three relevant categories
short range between 0 and 50 kilometers
mid range between 50 and 500 kilometers
and long range which is above 500
kilometers alright so i believe that
here we can already see the first
problem namely that flying cars just
don't make a lot of sense for short or
long ranges if your destination is
within a short range you can just walk
cycle take public transit or you know
you can just drive if those aren't an
option and if you're going long range
well then you can just take a train or
an airplane or just drive even because
flying cars just aren't that fast their
top speeds are generally 160 to 200
kilometers per hour which is a bit more
than highway speed essentially and is
very much inferior to high-speed rail
and vastly inferior to airplanes so the
practical use of flying cars is
basically limited to mid-range only also
you have to make sure that you can land
at or near the destination also also you
can't really use a flying car if the
weather is too bad you know if there's a
giant rainstorm or snowstorm or the
winds are too high also also also if
you're going at night you have to make
absolutely sure that your destination
has an illuminated landing area and the
thing about flying cars is that they are
essentially just foldable sports planes
as such their structure is very light
and so very vulnerable so if you go to a
store in say land mode and someone backs
into you in the parking lot and say
dance one of your flaps then you can't
really fly until it gets replaced so
every time you use your flying card in
land mode you are one slight bump away
from weeks of no flying and hundreds
perhaps thousands of dollars of service
fees alright so things aren't looking
great for the flying car so far you can
only really use it at a certain range in
good weather during daylight the
destination has to have landing
infrastructure and even with the
slightest damage you immediately have to
go to the repair shop alright so let's
move on to the second aspect of flying
cars namely the hazard they pose so
flying cars are essentially half a ton
projectiles flying around at moderate
speeds and in the case of mass adoption
there would also be a greater number of
accidents you know billy bob discovers a
dent on the right flap in the walmart
parking lot and thinks to himself yeah
it is probably fine and then it turns
out mid-flight that it's not really fine
because of issues like this flying cars
would basically need to be banned above
all human settlements and basically all
other strategically important
infrastructure for example military
installations airports seaports high
voltage cables and then there's also the
environmental considerations meaning
that flying cars would need to be bent
above nature reserves migratory bird
routes and any other areas where they
might end up damaging or disturbing the
local wildlife so in order to really
mitigate the hazard posed by flying cars
you would need to organize things
consider this map of budapest and its
surrounding areas so where would our
no-fly zones be turns out pretty much
everywhere so the only real solution
here is to essentially establish
corridors you know places where you can
concentrate flying cars and focus on
minimizing their negative consequences
and in order to avoid chaos on the roads
like flying cars randomly taking off and
landing you would need to establish a
whole bunch of huge airstrips where
potentially hundreds of flying cars can
take off or land at the same time and
all this would need to be coordinated of
course somehow so once again we are
talking about the mass adoption scenario
and wow what a great idea having these
focused busy transit corridors with some
major transit hubs along the way where
people can get on and off hmm if only
hungary had something like this it would
be such a great help you know something
which can move a lot of people
economically which is absolutely perfect
for middle distances something which
runs along these corridors and ends in
these big transit hubs so to speak and
someone should really call elon musk
about this because this [ __ ] needs the
inventing right now i mean this would
revolutionize our transit yeah um so
anyway the third and last aspect of
flying cars that i want to touch on is
your mental health you know even if
flying cars would be flying around
settlements they would still make a lot
of noise and this would be true even if
a flying car would be only as loud as a
regular car flying cars travel at an
altitude of around 2-3 kilometers
generally for comparison airliners
travel at around 10 kilometers now our
current land-based highways are already
super loud but we can soundproof them
with air corridors this is obviously not
possible so you would be looking at a
constant background buzzing even outside
cities or i should say especially
outside cities you know the places which
should be actually quieter and this of
course would have a devastating effect
on everybody's mental health no matter
what you do no matter where you go the
meddling buzzing will always be in your
ear and i don't know about you but for
me personally this would be a version of
hell and the thing is the more people
adopt flying cars the more severe these
problems get but then again i don't
think they'll be adopted in mess because
of the aforementioned problems they're
just too severe and all this renders the
concept of flying cars effectively
useless it's just another form of
inefficient individual transport which
we should be phasing out at this point
alright so this was my take on flying
cars and i haven't even mentioned things
like terrorism you know stuff like
loading your flying car with fertilizer
or something and then kamikaze into a
building or you know load up a bunch of
molotovs and use it as a bomber even
without these the case against flying
cars is strong enough i think so anyway
thank you for watching don't forget to
like and subscribe and do check out my
patreon if you think this content is
worth your money and i'll be seeing you
next time